[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bons voeux le monde
comment il était mal est content de
retrouver zot une semaine s'est
longtemps t-on enfin nous voilà on est
bien dans on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
à saint philippe chez samuel samuel
préfet samuel il a des fruits et l'inta
d'arbres fruitiers
mais attention des fruits rares oui du
coup de queue de boeuf sa pote tout ça
le connaît la lune adot encore maiden we
are d'autrui longtemps by faut consommer
des fruits arrêté un coup l'un d'accord
c'est bon tu donnes allait bien on y va
on va voir samuel là
m
[Musique]
comment les analyses combinées ça va
super way 5 août mais c'est d'accueil
dante pour ré tropicale andres is it
that les bienvenus c'est chouette du
mois où ça nous les exactement et ce que
tu fais ici nous les eaux barils à
saint-philippe où ça nous intéresse à
nous offrir à tout ce qui est rare est
cher c'est en partie vrai maintenant
nous savons faire des choses quand même
assez accessible pour le pour le plus
grand nombre si tu vois comme les
gentils de monsieur ben écoute tu sais
quoi
moi j'ai envie de tout de suite que tu
me montres tout ça parce que mal et très
curieux et amy adore les fruits allons à
malo allons allons allons
[Musique]
alors ça mais là nous les souks une bcs
et une petite partie de ce que vous
faites
oui effectivement là ici c'est
l'ombrière où ça nous c'est d'avoir une
représentation un petit peu de tout des
plantes que les prêts à être plantés
dans les cours et
et dans les vergers de lille du moment
qu'on dit fruits rares et fruits anciens
vous
quand on entend par là en fin de compte
qu'on nous parle de free rares note de
catégorie donc la première catégorie c
les fruits longtemps donc par exemple le
coeur de boeuf le sapotille que nous
doit venir corossol ça on va en parler
tout de suite quoi on lui indique tout
de suite parce que vous faites là depuis
longtemps nous disent abouti eh ben
c'est pas abouti ils appellent ça
corossol sa faute ici en quoi notre
variété de fruits et les vrais amis
m'avaient pas monter norma sur mon
terrain ont mené quelques nouveaux mâts
se montrent donc non la sympathique et
de boeuf après mangoustan mambo l'eau et
cetera et cetera
donc ça c'est le band free bhangra monte
à bitche avec qu'en est t thi my name is
adam lacko et c'est comme hélas ils
trouvent plus trop trop et sinon sa nana
des fruits d'introduction plus récente
que la pub est introduit même 30 ans 40
ans l'arrière mais prend l'exemple par
exemple de jaboticaba qu'ils commencent
à ressortir un petit peu aujourd'hui
ça c'est une introduction que là étaient
faits n'a pas longtemps donc la non dits
dans une seconde vague d'introductions
et nous nous intéresse
à nous aussi bien à l'une de com note
des catégories sachant que dans les
domaines à des choses très intéressant à
mettre en avant
[Musique]
ça c'est le longanis d'australie dont on
parle c'est pas le petit nom gagny pays
longtemps les différences à lui et
beaucoup plus gros donc la puce de chair
à manger sa différence aussi c'est que
la saison est beaucoup plus étalés et
commencent depuis deux mois de février
et les petits risques au mois de juillet
hier ouais bon ben salah sa pote m'a
mais effectivement ça c'est un fruit
d'introduction récente les colis flore
c'est à dire que son fruit n'est attaché
à même le tronc à même la branche il
fait qu'il donne à lier un côté très
spectaculaire quand il est en charge
[Musique]
là on a le même boulot démembrements
mollo malade au cas où kaka schatz a
connu à la réunion ce nom de kaka chatte
d'harcourt parce que lui n'est pas en
odeur assez particulier quand on lit des
murs
d'accord donc abricots des antilles bon
ça mais suppose que alors ça ça c'est
une introduction récente donc ça m'a
moins ceux de monique sonné ali à la
réunion ça c'est un gros fruits
avec une chair très juteuse en fin de
compte pourquoi abricots c'est plutôt la
couleur de ces chiens que il rappelle
l'abricot 1 et ensuite maintenant notre
cage où notre cage ou droit ça nous
connaît dans le type ball en apéritif
voilà plutôt par contre un peu de mou ni
koné que au dessus de la noix n'est là
c'est la somme dont elle faisait
également comme estime et à partir de
laquelle on peut faire un jus très
rafraîchissant chéri chou et la
c'est la famille dumont goustan le saf
ou une un goût très épicé qu'il peut
rappeler un petit peu l'origan certains
dit carrément que l'une un goût de
pizzas donc ça m'a fait quand même assez
assez spécial mais dis moi comment on la
connaît un conte ses fruits là en fin de
compte - depuis 2007 que mon est revenu
pour un stade amont à la réunion m'a
fait tout un travail de prospection à
l'échelle de l'ines nouer des contacts
avec des gens un petit peu comme moi
même passionné par tout ce band fruits
rares et du coup elle est vrai que ma
ronde à moins compte qu'on avait des
petits trésors dans certaines cours que
quand on regarde bien marché on trouve
les agrumes les mangues les letchis
sorti de là bas il faut fouiller un
petit peu alors que nous on a le
potentiel à la réunion pour acclimater
toutes ces espèces de fruits rares et
donc c'est plus de travail de commis 10
et de prospection comme on l'a fait et
grâce à ça on a pu mettre la main sur
des choses que mon à utiliser comme
pieds mères pour - refaire des plans
soient posées dès marcotte soit récupéré
des grès nexterra donc établir des
partenariats avec des gens un peu
disséminés sur l'ensemble de l'île en
plus des anomalies longue est là par
exemple j'ai pas le saf ou du mac
étaient originaires d'afrique est ce que
ça va ça c'est pareil chez shopi de bois
de la réunion même sa matraque sur un
petit banc la réunion à mes yeux à moi
je suis une personne qui en avait ça
dans sa cour et effectivement on a pu
remédier le plan d'autonomie pour ce
vraiment que en mai
c'est pas c'est pas des choses que vous
trouve donc comme ça où une cour là
bravo monsieur qui a le pied dans ce à
quoi c'est super génial messi pour nous
en quoi il consiste en deux journées
depuis ni risque c'est très diversifié
mais travaillé ces cinq millièmes aussi
dans ce travail là c'est que nous on
peut faire aussi bien
remplir des sachets bon bah ça c'est la
base qui est que nous ayons des plans
c'est pas le travail le plus machin mais
voilà on peut aller de là il faut le
faire après man et dans les semis en
l'occurrence ici nous laisse où acer de
semis donc une atmosphère quand même un
petit peu protégés ou sanou maîtrise les
éléments puisque quand les éléments se
déchaînent à saint-philippe ça peut
faire des dégâts
mais après mon mari n'a les opérations
plus techniques de greffage marcottage
oussalah c'est de travailler un peu plus
de précision quand même et puis après
nous aussi de le coter verger oussalah
nous l'a implanté les pieds mères donc
c'est le verger collection ousanousava
d'avoir un pied de chaque variété qu'il
permet anouma demain de prélever des
greffons de poser des marcotte pour
faire en sorte de multiplier et d'après
de diffuser au niveau de la pépinière
donc ça fait toute une palette de
travaux différents phase il faudra la
voilà en fonction des saisons nous va
mettre l'accent du développement de la
plante sur tel ou tel travail est comme
ça tout au long de l'année nadal a de
quoi faire
on s'ennuie pas là aujourd'hui mais dit
bravo spéciale dédicace
bravo nadir
[Musique]
colère piquée et amiens
alors samuel tu nous a emmenés dans ton
petit verger de savoir ce qu'on appelle
un berger collection donc c'est des
pieds mères comme l'a par exemple
hanouna des des mangues et on en a une
quinzaine de mangue et chaque pied c'est
une variété en particulier d'accord
voilà en fait j'ai vraiment un
une espèce d'encyclopédie que vous m
avec une variété cirque espèce en tant
que petit vivante effectivement
pour pouvoir prélever du matériel
végétal en l'occurrence les manguiers
c'est des greffons qu'on m'a prélevé
pour les greffés en pépinière et ensuite
pouvoir diffuser des pieds de mangue
léonard des pieds de mangue
émile des pieds de mangue etc
[Musique]
car la paix et la montagne
donc ce fameux je faisais ça petit
rappel un peu l'histoire
d'accord c'est que en fait le chapeau 2
6 que ni nous croient c'est pas du
sapotille c'est c'est le corossol cours
au sol et le sap haute si le vrai
sapotille
non les mamans
on peut voir aussi des fruits des petits
fruits qui eux seront pas mûres avant
l'année prochaine
une de ses particularités c'est que de
fruits va prendre à peu près 9 9 à 12
mois pour faire sa maturation c'est un
fruit longtemps mais que l'est la sla
pas du tout développés alors que c'est
un truc excellent mais délicat à
cultiver quand même dans le sens où si
vous plantez un grain de ça il fera au
compte huit à dix ans pour que le lit
commencent à fleurir
elle n'est pas garanti que lui donne est
donc c'est uniquement par greffage ou
par marcottage que nous va pouvoir
reproduire un spécimen comme celui ci
que les très productif comme ça tu peux
voir
ouais et ben là nous peut envisager de
lancer une production
mais si vous compte sur plante un grain
laisse pousser la 10 ont perdu le temps
quelque sorte
mais vous voyez des films commencent
réfléchi avant l'aller d'hommes marcher
trappe de 3 pour planter là eh ben non
on pourra pas donc j'ai signé ici le
parquet
[Musique]
déjà décrit un petit peu ce que n'a là
dedans parce que ses juges julie alors
ça là c'est quoi
ben ça c'est
c'est donc le corossol c'est donc le
fameux sac moody sa pote ne s'est passé
ensuite
ensuite ben voilà une diversité de
cabosses de cacao
le vrai ça motive les cinq ou six mois
la voilà que nous peut goûter leur a
tout de suite ajouté
comme ça on va faire un profit des
messages
ça c'est la sapo john assez exceptionnel
d'accord écoute pendant qu'on coupe
c'est avec nounous déguste manade trois
petites questions opposa ou dis-moi
comment tu en est arrivé à la bonde
germond a grandi
en milieu rural à la campagne entourée
de champs de blé et de maïs betterave
dans le nord de la france mais en
attendant intime armes à imiter cours
dans les champs et caetera et caetera et
mon papa tu es passionné de jardins
aussi il faut dire que 18 ans j'ai
choisi la voie agricole je fais un bts
agricole à la martinique
et puis là tout de suite dont j'ai senti
que c'était mon affaire quoi que j'étais
j'avais fait le bon choix
et du coup après j'ai continué à me
former tout de suite j'ai choisi aussi
le volet
l'alternative du bio pour parce que moi
c'était un souhait de rapprocher à moins
de la nature voilà est un projet
d'extension dans un futur proche pour se
lancer vraiment sur la production de ces
fruits donc les fruits en eux-mêmes donc
avec notamment le fric que vient de
goûter la méconnaît pas si d'après vous
est ce que n'aurait un créneau
oui pour développer en affaires il vaut
la peine à creuser me trouve que
largement oui d'autant plus que les bons
d'autant plus que les saints est
d'autant plus que les doux bah écoutes
je pense qu'on a fait un peu le tour on
retrouve samuel la première à la
prochaine mais au plaisir mais c'est
beaucoup possèdent farandole de goût
mais a plus tard à l'été
et voilà mamaï l'émission se termine ben
oui c'est comme ça ne plaît pas ne
pleurez pas je reviendrai
alors on s'est arrêté tout simplement au
plus des anglais à saint-philippe
derrière la piscine
devant on a le petit kiosque est nommé à
faire mon carrie ce midi tu es là même
tout de suite je vous dis tout
simplement à la prochaine et on n'est
pas du tout sorti de l'auberge
moi je vous le dis et de façon nous
affirmons karité elle a aimé ça mange
tes à la wii marmaille t elle à la
[Musique]